[Musique]
chauffeurs de taxi, vous connaissez probablement un
film qui m'a vraiment donné envie d'être
acteur et un type particulier d'acteur, donc
je suis sûr que vous savez que cela m'a influencé
d'une certaine manière, mais il n'y a pas eu de
décision consciente
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
J'ai été végétalien pratiquement toute ma
vie et je n'utilise pas de produits d'origine animale
qui utilisent du cuir Je pensais que
j'évitais la laine Je n'ai jamais su que les costumes
étaient en laine J'ai réalisé que c'était
quelque chose que je voulais  évitez
[Musique]
Je ne me sens rien ça bouge juste
sa redécouvre autre chose
[Musique]
c'était complètement inattendu en fait
avant que je vienne ici j'ai dit à ma copine
que ça allait être ouais donc ça va
être une très bonne expérience parce que euh je
était j'allais me faire écraser et ce serait
vraiment humiliant a été vraiment
important de vivre une expérience dans
laquelle vous êtes vous Nana a unanimement
détesté
[Musique]
Je pense qu'il a beaucoup d'empathie c'est
quelqu'un qui est très éthique c'est
quelqu'un qui est  prêt à faire tout ce qu'il
doit faire pour défendre ce qu'il pense être l'
intégrité
il est
terriblement drôle